today we have the new m1 ipad air i'm so
excited to check this out not only does
it have the new m1 chip but it also has
5g so let's start unboxing and check it
out
since we're in the kitchen we use a
kitchen knife and today we're actually
shooting this video at 8k so i thought
we would switch up the set a little just
do a nice little unboxing in the kitchen
why not so this is actually the new blue
color of the ipad i can't wait to see it
so this is the ipad air 5th gen this is
the wi-fi plus cellular it is always so
nice having this always connected
[Music]
this blue
is so pretty this actually looks way
better in person than it did online like
i thought the blue looked great but like
take a look at this
this is a great color wow
so into it got our paperwork oh boy okay
fingers crossed that the apple sticker
is blue
okay it's not but that's okay i'm not
upset about it
so we've got our usbc cable and our
power brick the new ipad air is also
compatible with the magic keyboard and i
love this thing so much if you've
watched any of my ipad reviews you guys
know that i am the biggest fan of the
magic keyboard one because it kind of
turns this ipad into more of a computer
laptop type device it has the trackpad
it also adds in an additional little
usbc port here that allows for
pass-through charging and this is
amazing because that will also give you
access to the usb-c port on the ipad so
that basically gives you a charging port
and a data port which is incredible if
you're actually using this to do
anything where you need to charge and be
able to transfer data i also like that
they came out with a white version of it
too so they do have two colors the black
and the white look at you look at you
look at you
so here you'll see the track pad your
keyboard and this is the smart connector
that allows basically the case to
connect to your ipad and it also allows
like i said for the pass through
charging and of course we have the apple
pencil i'm not gonna lie i have spent
the last three months drawing a uh a
project if you've been following me on
twitter you probably have a really good
guess what it is the apple pencil on my
ipad has pretty much been attached to my
body for the past several months all
that to say
this is compatible with the apple pencil
too
also the apple pencil is an incredible
hair tie device if you saw my tik tok
you know of course the ipad
and apple pencil just docks right here
up at the top which not only charges it
but connects it as well and one last
piece to our new ipad air puzzle is this
is the smartfolio and this doesn't have
a keyboard attached this is less
expensive and it basically will just
keep your ipad safe and you can also do
a few different configurations here for
different ways to view your content this
blue is so perfect this is like a
perfect
shade like i love the compliments of
this light blue with the dark blue and
that's one thing that apple really does
such a great job of is making sure that
all of their accessories have really
great complementing colors so let's put
this
onto the smart folio so you guys can see
what that looks like and this is so much
lighter than the magic keyboard like
that is one thing is this does add a
little extra weight it's time to set up
this is always the most exciting part
[Music]
this is one of my favorite features
about the ipad air is the fact that they
have touch id on the power button and
it's added this already has a cellular
5g for verizon in it oh light mode or
dark mode
i think i'm gonna go with light mode and
that's it it's all set up now i guess i
gotta install some apps and get ready to
test
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
how's it going dude it's going good
how's everything over there i'm in
hawaii i'm so jealous this is my
favorite place so i'm testing out center
stage check this out watch i can go all
the way over here
my iphone
but this is so cool
the quality online looks great dude you
actually look incredible too like you've
got the bokeh behind you too which is
awesome you got the blurry because i'm
using the new iphone yeah so
doing a little cooking okay i'm going
over here
going over here
i'm actually kind of impressed with your
audio too like it sounds great can you
see me all the way over here
have fun in hawaii
bye
[Music]
so it's coffee time and i of course
brought the ipad air and what i'm going
to do is i'm actually going to film a
little vlog of getting the coffee
ordering the coffee whatever on my
iphone what's great about shooting on
the iphone is i can either take all of
this footage air drop it to the ipad or
what's even better is it syncs to the
cloud and it's automatically on the ipad
ready to edit lumafusion i guess i'm
just going to make my little vlog now
hello justine here really important
message i'm going to the coffee bean and
tea leaf and i'm going to get a
pomegranate blueberry tea latte
[Music]
i also brought one of my owc drives
which is great because i can just plug
in and connect this to our usbc port
now everything was air dropped from my
phone to the ipad so i plugged in my
drive because i have some music and some
clips so if this was like a bigger edit
and i wanted to bring some external
footage that i had shot elsewhere i have
all of that on here it's really loud
here though this is not ideal working
conditions for me noise canceling
airpods pro max yes please i'm gonna
find some music on my drive and add this
to the mix
[Music]
my edit is complete and i am so in love
with editing on the ipad like i forget
how incredible it is until you actually
sit down and learn the program it's so
awesome having a touch-based environment
sometimes you just want to reach out and
just scroll on that timeline but yeah
here's the the final edit it's my best
work cheers
[Music]
the one way you could tell if somebody's
cool or not is if they have
enough guts to go out in public and
take photos of their ipad look at me
look at me look at me look how cool look
how cool i look i mean even though you
might look silly taking pictures with
such a massive device like the camera is
pretty incredible so more power to you
let's normalize taking photos and videos
on the ipad
yeah gotta get the shot
[Music]
hey guys it's ai justine here this is my
new body my new form i hope you're into
it
now drop it
i love it
[Music]
so there are a lot of ipads in front of
me but this is the one that we're
talking about today this is the ipad air
it's the fifth generation which is
bringing the m1 chip 5g connectivity it
has an improved ultra wide front camera
featuring center stage and eight core
cpu eight core graphics with next-gen
neural engine and eight gigs of ram you
can get up to ten hours of battery life
on wi-fi or nine hours on cellular you
can also now record up to 60 frames a
second in 1080p on the front camera and
take 12 megapixel photos which is up
from 7 on the previous ipad air you can
also now shoot with extended dynamic
range in both the front and the rear
camera i think a lot of people are going
to be kind of confused now with the
introduction of another ipad that has an
m1 chip so back here this is the 12.9
inch ipad pro with m1 this is the 11
inch ipad pro m1 and this is the new
10.9 inch ipad air with m1 chip so
looking at the smaller ipad pro in
comparison to the new m1 ipad air one of
the biggest differences is that the pro
ipad has a pro motion display and this
gives you an extra fluid feel when
you're actually using it now this
doesn't make that much of a difference
on the usability but it is really hard
to go back to a non-pro motion display
after using one with it for so long you
can get a pro ipad with storage up to
two terabytes where the ipad air you're
maxed out at 256 gigs now you do have
upgraded cameras with the pro with a 12
megapixel wide 10 megapixel ultra wide
plus lidar now the air only has the 12
megapixel wide camera and there's no
lidar you will get faster transfer
speeds with the usb and thunderbolt 4
ports in the pro and they also do have
millimeter wave support so that will
allow you to have faster 5g there are
two speakers in the air and there's four
in the pro and the pro has face id but
it doesn't have touch id like the air
does in the power button i am so excited
i just updated my ipad and the new mac
os monterey so we can test out universal
control now with this i can use a mouse
and a keyboard and i can control not
only my ipad but i can also control my
macbook which these two displays are
hooked up to and you can also have one
other device as well so you can have
three different mac products and i'll
control them with one mouse one keyboard
and the cool thing about this is being
able to drag and drop files from your
ipad to your macbook and then maybe from
the macbook to another imac that you
have set up it kind of gives you this
whole little universe all in one hence
universal control okay anyway let's try
it i'm so excited to get this all
started you go into the display setting
and in here you'll see there's a new
universal control option so let's click
it
your cursor and keyboard can be used on
any nearby mac or ipad signed into your
icloud i've got a lot of computers um
around so i don't know what's gonna
happen
oh look at this link keyboard and mouse
oh it just popped up look it's right
here and what's cool is i love being
able to like move this around so you can
kind of mimic the desktop setup that you
have
oh my goodness look at this
this is my mouse do you see
i'm controlling this this is game
changing this is absolutely the game has
been changed the game that you knew
before is no more so this is kind of a
project that i already started it was a
little animation so it kind of like goes
like this look at that and then we have
some key presses here so i drew all of
this in procreate all of the various key
presses i just exported all of these as
separate files all right i'm going to
see what's going to happen when i drag
all of these files over
they're sliding off
of the ipad
onto
the macbook and now i'm just gonna
drag and oh my god they're right there
so this makes it super easy to go
through and then i made my little
animation with each key press so that
was sort of my first impressions and
first demo testing out universal control
i'm so excited to test this out further
i definitely want to try it using three
different devices so for now that's how
i plan on using my ipad with universal
control and with my macbook because this
is kind of like my main setup and this
is how i've been working for the past
couple of months since i got the new
macbook pro now i'm gonna throw it to my
friend jake who's been helping me shoot
some photos and videos and he actually
uses his ipad pro as his main photo
editing device so it's like hey why
don't you test out the ipad air show us
your workflow and see what you think
jake take it away yeah and then you take
it away okay yep love it okay
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody jake here
and as justine just mentioned i'm a
photographer full-time and i have
implemented my ipad pro into my workflow
and when she gave me a call about giving
this ipad air a try i kind of geeked out
so i'm going to give you guys a little
insight on my workflow now something
that i love that apple started doing
back in 2018 with their 11 inch ipad pro
is implementing the usb-c port on the
side that means that i can plug in an
external hard drive or better yet for my
workflow i can put my sd card reader or
card reader in general straight into the
ipad throw it into lightroom and start
editing now i do have to keep in mind
that if i'm importing a lot of images
that i am kind of stuck with how much
storage the ipad has on board now i
absolutely love the apple pencil
especially when it comes to lightroom
mobile the first thing that i like to do
is go in and change the color profile to
match my camera now that i've got that
done i'm going to mess with some of the
colors and some of the exposures until i
find something that i really like okay
so i've definitely got my exposure in a
comfortable place i'm going to jump
straight into the masking and fine-tune
some details and i see over here that
it's got some of her in that mask and i
don't want that so i'm going to subtract
from that mask
use the brush tool to brush anything
that is highlighted in red away now that
i got the subject masked out of this
photo i can make any adjustments to just
that specific part of the photo i
absolutely love just how fast the ipad
is able to compute this one of the last
places that i like to edit is in the
effects tab so let's go ahead and open
that up pull down a little bit of the
clarity and then pop a little bit of
dehaze on there and add a little bit of
vignette so it isolates that ipad even
more so i'm going to crop this down to
16x9 so i make sure that everything will
fit perfectly into a 16x9 thumbnail for
youtube overall i am very impressed by
this ipad comparing it to my 12.9 inch
ipad pro i really noticed no difference
i mean the display is nice and bright
everything's nice and fast and i was
able to get the job done just as easily
as i would have on my ipad pro and the
fact that this is about half the cost of
that definitely means that there's going
to be a lot of people giving me a run
for my money out there let's see it
what do we think oh dude i think that
actually that might be the thumbnail oh
really
here's a little bit before and after for
you
before oh after
yeah that's a huge difference you like
it i love it sweet
[Music]
now cost wise for wi-fi you're looking
at a starting price of 5.99 for 64 gigs
in the air and the base pro model starts
at 128 gigs for 7.99 i think it really
comes down to price how much internal
storage you think you're going to need
will you need faster transfer speeds
with a thunderbolt 4 on the pro but i
really think for most people you're
going to be pretty happy with the new
ipad air because it can do just about
everything that you'd need for all of my
illustration stuff i've been using the
ipad pro and it's kind of interesting
because when you're using procreate the
amount of layers that you're able to
create depends on the amount of ram that
your device has so the 128 the 256 and
the 512 gig ipad models only have eight
gigs of ram but if you choose the one
terabyte or two terabyte options that
then gives you a completely specked up
ipad giving you 12 gigs of ram all that
being said price is a huge factor so the
fact that you can do basically
everything that these m1 pro ipads can
do here on the ipad air yes there are
some limitations but i feel like that is
something that you easily can work
around if you need it so i'm very
excited about this introduction of this
new ipad into the family i look forward
to continuing to test that out and i am
so looking forward to seeing what you
guys think of these devices i'm a huge
ipad fan and i am so excited to kind of
see them out in the wild and see what
you guys create and if you're not
creating that's fine consume content
we're also consumers it's also pretty
great for playing video games thank you
guys so much for watching if you guys
have any questions please leave them in
the comments below and if you want to
check out my new little project that
i've been working on feel free to follow
along twitter.com jpg and also on
instagram jpeg.farm and if you want to
also sign up in the mailing list so
you'll be alerted when the alpha is
gonna be dropped you guys can sign up on
the website jpeg.form i love the ipad it
has honestly changed my life over the
past couple of months just using it in a
way that i never thought that i would
ever use an ipad i never really thought
that illustration was something that i
would get back into so i've been having
the best time and i hope that you guys
can find something that inspires you to
kind of unlock something that you never
thought that you would do again like
whether it's playing a sport or drawing
or maybe you want to start making videos
and that must be the sign that i have to
plug in my ipad and it's time to go so
i'll see you guys later
bye perfect timing little ipad
[Music]
[Applause]
you